hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will ich habe heute kein rezept
und auch kein tutorial für euch auch
wenn sie es so aussieht mir dieser torte
aber die steht jetzt einfach nur dabei
weil es einfach zum thema dazu passt
denn ich habe ja bereits schon
angekündigt auf facebook und auf
instagram dass sich dieses jahr auf
allen vier kickwelt messen teilnehmen
werde
die cache bolt messen das sind
deutschlandweit echte größten messen wo
es einfach um torten und kuchen ums
backen und ums dekorieren geht und es
findet dieses jahr in vier städten statt
13 in deutschland eine ist in österreich
und da freue ich mich schon richtig
drauf denn ich habe auch ganz ganz viele
österreichische zuschauer und habe ja
schon immer gesagt ich möchte mal nach
österreich kommen ich komm mal nach wien
und es ist jetzt einfach dieses jahr
ich sage euch vielleicht jetzt schon mal
einfach die termine damit ihr das
einfach schon mal ist im märz fertig in
hamburg seien im mai in friedrichshafen
in wien werde ich dann im september und
oktober ist hannover
das heißt ich habe ich vier termine und
die ganz genauen daten also das ganz
genau datum steht unten in meiner
infobox oder auch auf der homepage von
der cache world messe deutschland und es
sind immer insgesamt jeweils drei tage
das heißt ich bin auch alle drei tage
immer auf der messe deswegen hört bitte
auf beim veranstalter anzurufen
denn der krieg schon anrufe an welchen
tagen ich da bin ich bin echt an allen
drei tagen da es gibt natürlich auch
jetzt schon karten im vorverkauf der
bekommt ihr bei mir im shop ist
natürlich auch günstiger wir werden ihr
es jetzt dort vor ort kauft das könnt
ihr praktisch also jetzt schon machen
euch die tickets sichern und dann sehen
wir uns einfach dort bei mir was einfach
so die veranstalter kate die haben mich
einfach angerufen und kontaktiert und
haben gefragt ob ich da nicht denn stand
machen will und ich mein ich bin jetzt
kein riesenunternehmen ich bin einfach
eine kleine youtube in die bisse backt
und kocht und deswegen besser auch für
mich jetzt unmöglich gewesen einfach
jetzt da hinzugehen anstand zu machen
denn sonst stand zu machen und die
standmiete zu zahlen den stand überhaupt
aufzubauen
das kostet wirklich richtig viel geld
weil man da einfach viel investieren
muss in alles was da eben steht und
deswegen habe ich mich mit firmen
zusammengeschlossen und hab gesagt komm
ich so jetzt einfach sponsoren die
mieter helfen
und mein größter sponsor auf dieser
messen oder auf diesen messen wird jetzt
die firma kennwort sein
wir werden da einfach gemeinsam entstand
haben und bisher war es immer so wenn
ich auf ständen war habe ich immer was
vorgeführt hat was gebacken hat was
dekoriert und hatte aber so ein bisschen
weniger zeit für meine zuschauer denn
ich weiß einfach wenn ihr zu mir kommt
und weiß ich ihr wollt euch mit mir
unterhalten aber manche scheuen sich
dann dafür weil ich dann gerade was der
kurier und reden dann vielleicht nicht
so viel
und das machen wir dieses mal anders die
firma kenwood wird einfach den stand
machen
ich werde auch mit dabei sein jemand
wird das sein der etwas vorführt ich
werde natürlich auch was machen was
dekorieren aber eben eher als kleineres
und dann habe ich eben umso mehr zeit
für euch und kann mich mit euch
unterhalten wir uns kennenlernen und ich
freue mich schon riesig darauf vor allem
finde ich sogar so faszinierend dass ich
ja nicht nur so eine altersgruppe die
dann vorbei kommt wie man sich
vielleicht vorstellt so irgendwie die
muttis sondern das sind wirklich kinder
mit dabei das sind ältere mitarbeiter
sind frauen männer mit dabei ist
wirklich alles mit dabei und ich find's
einfach faszinierend und echt spannend
zu sehen wer hinter der kamera
wer hinter dem laptop oder hinter dem
fernseher steht und mir einfach zu
schaut vor allen dingen sind deshalb
schön einfach mal gesichter zu den
ganzen namen zu sehen
ich weiß zum beispiel in wien werde ich
zum beispiel die ena kaiser treffen das
ist eine die verfolgt mich schon von
anfang an ich weiß noch als ich mein
online shop gegründet habe habe ich in
dem video ich noch die ina erwähnt weil
sie immer so viel kommentiert hat und
das zeigt mir einfach was für eine
bindung wir alle miteinander haben und
deswegen werde ich auch an allen drei
tagen darf sein und bemühe mich
natürlich für jeden einzelnen viel zeit
aufzubringen und ich freue mich schon
riesig und ich würde mich einfach total
freuen wenn ihr dabei seid schaut euch
auf jeden fall unter dem video in der
infobox die termine an
und ja ich freue mich auf euch alle du
hast vergessen
ach gott ja das ist doch das besondere
fange ja ganz vergessen eigentliches
highlight und zwar geht es da immer so
ein torten wettbewerb das heißt ihr
könnt euch doch bewerben da gibt es
verschiedene kategorien und dann könnte
ebene torte backen dekorieren und nimmt
sie damit auf die messe und nehmt
einfach an diesem wettbewerb teil und
ich sitze da in der jury und da freue
ich mich schon richtig drauf ich meine
es wird bestimmt auch einige geben die
viel besser integrieren als ich finde es
trotzdem cool auf der interviewer emi
dabei zu sein
das ganze ist anonym und keiner weiß wer
die torte gemacht hat es wird dann
ausgewertet und ich hoffe mit kenwood
vereinbart dass der hauptpreis eine
küchenmaschine ist und zwar ist die die
jetzt im hintergrund stets eigentlich
auch gleich und das finde ich richtig
faszinierend das heißt wegen ihr gerne
backt wenn ihr gerne dekoriert schaut
euch mal auf der homepage alle daten an
wo ihr da teilnehmen könnt macht mir
kommt mit einer torte ich freue mich das
schon drauf dann sehe ich auch mal eure
kunstwerke und nicht immer ihr nur meine
und das ist so das richtig große
highlight auf der messe zu einer
küchenmaschine das hier ist übrigens der
hauptgewinn das ist die neue can go
chefs fans und ich will keine oder fast
keine kosten gespart und verlust
wirklich vier maschinen auf also auf
allen vier messen events eine maschine
die von uns es nicht also die verlosung
cnet gibt es natürlich zum gewinnen wenn
ihr eine torte macht und die daneben
gewinnt und es ist wirklich ein toller
preis
ich finde da lohnt sich wirklich auch
auf jeden fall mit zu machen also echt
strengt euch an
denkt euch eine richtig super torte aus
und gestaltet sie bringt sie mit und ich
wette mit euch eine folge mit gewinnen
natürlich bin ich nicht die einzige die
auf der messe ist da gibt's auch ganz
viele andere firmen viele shops und da
gibt es auch workshops und ihr könnt ja
einfach daran teilnehmen da könnt euch
vorher anmelden soweit ich weiß
schaut euch einfach die homepage von
kate von der cache welt an
und da steht alles drin was man wissen
muss und ich freue mich echt schon auf
euch alle
schreibt mir mal in die kommentare wer
zu welchem termin wohin kommt dann kann
ich schon ein bissel stelle und kann mir
auf facebook so teure profile angucken
und ich gehe diese art
und der morath geht auch mal gucken wer
kennt ja die türken wie es war nicht so
auf politik und geschichte woran ich
freue mich echt auf euch alle auf
hamburg hannover friedrichshafen und wie
vor allem wen also ich war noch nie in
wien und deswegen ist für mich echtes
highlight dieses jahr
ich freue mich auf euch bis bald